der assistenzeinsatz des
österreichischen bundesheers beim
schneechaos 2009 10 ist für beendet
erklärt worden
verteidigungsminister mario kunasek
erklärte in einer aussendung dass ohne
die grundwehrdiener der einsatz in
dieser form nicht möglich gewesen wäre
die österreicherinnen und österreicher
könnten stolz auf ihre soldaten seien
tatsächlich waren in spitzenzeiten bis
zu 1700 soldatinnen und soldaten im
einsatz unterstützt von hubschraubern
pionier fahrzeugen und sonstigen
schweren gerät 850 personen konnten
durch evakuierungsflüge per hubschrauber
in sicherheit gebracht werden
mehr als zehn tonnen lebensmittel und
dringend benötigte medizinische güter
wurden per luftbrücke transportiert
ebenfalls alternativlos war der einsatz
des bundesheeres beim freischaufeln von
dächern räumen von straßen und beim
wiederherstellen von gekappten fernmelde
verbindungen
als dank für den unermüdlichen einsatz
hat verteidigungsminister kunasek den
jeweiligen einsatz entsprechende
dienstfreistellungen für die
einsatzkräfte angeordnet das sei eine
wertschätzung für die geleistete arbeit
zu den minister in einer aussendung
[Musik]